[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar with another addition to the MHA
facts series this time we are talking
about Todoroki aka Jon Snow the legend
who is simultaneously associated with
both Ice and Fire
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
my hero academia videos I've done eight
so far about other MHA students so this
is the night
Todoroki has been requested from the
beginning but I wanted to do some less
popular characters first before I got to
this heavy-hitter feel free to suggest a
character that you are burning up to see
just make sure it's not one I've already
done now without further ado let's jump
into it back number one if you've
watched any previous MHA fact videos you
should know by now that hoodie cause she
always puts a lot of thought into the
naming of his characters the middlee in
medoras name means green while the COG a
in fumika gays name means shadow pretty
self-explanatory show total hockey is no
exception
show toes name contains the kanji for
burning and freezing which perfectly
reflects his quirk half cold half hot he
can use his fire powers to burn things
while he uses his ice powers to freeze
things beyond his quirk though the terms
hot and cold can be applied to Shoto in
different ways too at first
Todoroki is cold and standoffish this
likely has to do with his abusive father
issues but he starts out as a loner and
doesn't like getting too close to people
at the same time though he does begin to
warm up to people especially after the
you a sports festival where he
interestingly enough starts using his
fireside again which he had repressed
because of his hatred towards his
firebending father ironically despite
his often cold attitude Mina thinks he's
the hottest boy in class 1-a
lastly let's touch upon his surname
Todoroki
Todoroki is a common surname in japan
even his surname is significant when we
see Totoro keys room we see that is the
only traditional japanese-style room he
also explains that his family home was
made in the Japanese style as well
furthermore
his favorite food is Zota soba aka cold
soba this dish is associated with Japan
and has been eaten in the country for
centuries clearly his common Japanese
surname reflects the fact that he is a
traditional Japanese guy in many
respects fact number two I mentioned
that sholto's father was a firebender
and that wasn't an accident so let's
turn to Avatar The Last Airbender next
we know that hood eco she loves Western
comics shows and movies he has a
ridiculously expensive superhero
collection in his house and he's a huge
fan of Star Wars he even did a Star Wars
cosplay and made an anime style movie
poster for Star Wars the last Jedi he
often draws motivation from these
Western works for instance gran torino
is obviously inspired by Yoda and the
class 1b student with the beasts quark
is clearly inspired by the beast from
x-men taking all this into account it is
all but certain that Shoto was inspired
to a degree by Zuko from Avatar The Last
Airbender the similarities between the
two characters go on and on a person
could make a whole video comparing the
two so here I'll just give a few
significant parallels they can both bend
fire they both started out not getting
along with the protagonist and ended up
warming up to them later
they are both haunted by their daddy
issues they both have horrible burn
marks over there left eyes that seemed
to only increase how attracted they are
to members of the opposite sex
obviously there are differences like
that Sholto is a bender of fire and ice
but there always will be differences
back number three next let's talk about
my boy Totoro Kees popularity in Japan
and abroad so the rookie started strong
and came in second place in the first
between a Zuko and Bakura he came in
third place in the second pole between
Zuko and shuttle Aizawa he came in third
again in the third Pole this time
between a Zuko and my other boy red
Metapod in the fourth Pole Todoroki
moved up to second place speeding out
midoriya for the first time but he still
couldn't take back who goes Iron Throne
so as you can see Todoroki is very
popular in Japan despite the fact that
there are so many other cool and hot
characters in MHA
he is consistently in the top three
which is saying a lot
interestingly enough Todoroki was less
popular in the US than in Japan in the
first English poll he came in sixth
place between Bach ago and chicken
Batman in the second poll he came in
fourth wedged between two girls
hemoccult Olga and soo you who came
right behind him in the latest English
poll Todoroki came in third place behind
a zoo ku and Baku go
so Todoroki is still popular in the West
and getting more popular as time goes on
but he isn't as consistently in the top
three as he is in Japan let me know what
you think that we the audience in the
West don't seem to appreciate him as
much are we just too obsessed with girls
will have long tongues and or wanna kill
us fact number four if you are a
Todoroki fan you need to check out
horikoshi she's twitter where you can
find countless sketches of Shoto made by
the my hero academia creator you'll find
rare instances of Todoroki fishing
playing soccer and possessing
ridiculously big eyes you'll see him in
Rudolph the reindeer cosplay and doing
whatever this is the list goes on and I
won't mention every sketch but I will
say that there are sketches that further
play up many people's favorite ship
Todoroki X Momo in one image Todoroki
looks at Momo while she looks shyly away
in another there just hanging out and
playing with a cat all signs point
towards a Totoro ki x yo-yos ooh baby
and you can let me know in the comments
what you think the babies Opie quirk
would be fact number 5 let's talk about
toda Rocky's hero costume the old one
completely covered up his left side aka
the side that has his father's quirk and
features this costume was symbolic he
wanted to have nothing to do with his
abusive father so much so that he hated
even the parts of himself that reminded
him of his father including his flames
his red hair and his turquoise eye he
wanted to hide his father's features and
repress his quirk
however after dec who helps him see that
it's his own quirk and he begins to
accept every part of himself he
undergoes a costume change which is
ironically much cooler than the old
mister
freeze one this new costume is made so
that Todoroki can utilize both his
freezing and burning powers the hero
costume senses Totoro keys body heat and
automatically applies cooling and
heating as needed
this is necessary because Todoroki can
get frostbite if he uses his ice side
too much although using his fireside
also helps prevent frostbite the costume
is made with specific fibers that are
ridiculously heat resistant and won't
just burn away when Todoroki uses his
fire quirk so the Rocky's utility belt
is not as exciting as Batman's he
carries vials of water disinfectants and
other medicines in it for rescue
operations the soles of show toes boots
are made similar to soccer cleats
so that Todoroki doesn't accidentally
slip on his own ice lastly horikoshi
lets us know that all in all the costume
is cool on him and the shameless puns
that I love so much keep on coming back
number 6
according to the official character book
Todoroki scored a 5 out of 5 in power a
4 out of 5 and speed a 5 out of 5 and
technique a 4 out of 5 in intelligence
and a 3 out of 5 in cooperativeness thus
with such impressive stats it's no
surprise that Todoroki was one of the
recommended students along with his
sweet yo-yo zoo and the attack Titan
from class 1b it's not a surprise that
his cooperativeness can use some work
since he comes from an abusive home that
has likely made him more standoffish
than most but he is getting better and
better with that as a story goes on if
we take Totoro keys overall score of 21
out of 25 he comes out with the highest
score in class 1a even beating out
momoyo euros ooh who scored an
impressive 20 out of 25 herself so yeah
Todoroki is not just talented he's
redonkulous ly talented back number 7
for this fact let's talk about some of
the behind-the-scenes details about
Todoroki as I previously mentioned and
as you might have already known Todoroki
got in on recommendations along with
momoyo zoo and juice alone a new key
from class 1b but what you may not know
is that horikoshi bell
like he had to apologize to fans because
the inclusion of recommended students
into class 1a and class 1 be confused so
many readers lots of people wrote
messages to him asking why there were 20
students enrolled in class 1a when in
chapter 5 he wrote that there were 18
kids to a class hoodie quashy later
cleared this up and explained that since
Todoroki and yoyo Razoo were enrolled
through official recommendations they
weren't counted among the 18 another
behind-the-scenes fact about Todoroki is
that horikoshi came up with him very
early on in the brainstorming process
about right after he came up with the
ideas for azúcar Katsuki and/or choco
fact number 8 in the japanese Todoroki
is voiced by the 33 year old Yuki Kaji
he also voices Eren Jaeger in attack on
Titan and malleolus along with zelgius
in the seven deadly sins Yuki is very
talented and has won many awards for his
voice acting at the say you or Japanese
voice actor Awards he got the best
rookie award and later he won the best
leading voice actor award two years in a
row in 2013 and 2014 the awards were
specifically for his portrayal of Issei
in highschool DxD and Aaron in attack on
Titan toad rookies younger self was
portrayed by the voice actress kay
Shindo who also voices Jiro fact number
9 in the English dub Todoroki is voiced
by the 44 year-old David Matranga David
also has a lot of great roles under his
belt including Tony Okazaki from Clannad
one of my favorite anime series and he
makes a colossal appearance in attack on
Titan as well in 2013 he got an award
for his portrayal of the wolf man in
wolf children which so happens to be one
of my favorite anime movies younger
Todoroki is voiced by Michaela Krantz
who voiced the younger version of other
epic characters like fellow firebender
Peugeot Leone from black clover and Levi
from attack on Titan she was also the
also crazy Clementine in overlord fact
number 10 and as usual we have a
lightning round
in lieu of
single fact we're going plus ultra and
we're gonna cover as many Todoroki facts
as we can in a relatively short period
of time okay three two one let's jam
Todoroki is 176 centimeters or about
five foot nine inches tall making it the
sixth tallest in the class he's fifteen
meaning he's younger than Momo totally
making her a cougar his birthday is on
January 11th making him a Capricorn
his blood type is o Shoto ranked fifth
in class one day's midterm scores and
second in aizawa's quick apprehension
past while cougar Momo got first in both
he is student number 15 in class 1a and
has the least creative hero name since
he just uses his first name Soto all
signs point to Dobby in fact being his
brother
lastly Todoroki has heterochromia which
is what it is called when someone has
different colored eyes heterochromia can
even affect hair and we see that in
Todoroki last summer during an epic euro
trip I posted a picture of a dog I saw
with heterochromia on our Instagram and
you guys athlete dubbed it a Todoroki
dog I actually first saw this condition
in an anime shut up - you know me
Kanzaki from great teacher onizuka and
that is it for today's video
smash that like button if you enjoyed
the video if you haven't don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you get notified for future videos
speaking of future videos give me
suggestions for what MHA characters
you'd like to see done next thanks again
for your support and until next time see
ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]